[Music]
[Applause]
For the realization of a giant tea bar,
an approximate time
of six months is used
before a structure alone weighs almost
12 quintals of weight,
we expect around 130,000
people who visit us throughout the
day and said  Visitors come from all
over the world and for whom they
come to visit and want to see the
majestic kites of Guatemalan bread.
Well, my name is Julio Roberto. I'm very
young. I have been making kites
for 24 years.
[Music]
[Applause]
celebration
the celebration of the
kite festival here is a piece of bread that
has been carried out for many years, perhaps
300 years now, and in it there is an
oral history where it says that precisely
on November 2,
God is told that he gave
permission to all the spirits  that he went down
to earth to visit his relatives
then together with the good
spirits also says that the
bad spirits came down which  they came to
bother those who rested in the cemetery
on facebook which admits they rate
dollars
for the making of a kite
precisely everything is done or started in the
family so the grandparents the parents
the uncles are the ones who instill one to
get into  being able to make or design a
kite
[Music]
then all the emotion that one
puts there makes on November 1,
19, his bar in lt ria jumped, he
shouts with emotion to see that his
kite has risen
[Music]